Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To
Do at The SCP Foundation: Dr. Bright cannot
use “My evil twin did it” as a viable
excuse.
The same goes for “My good twin did it”,
considering the implication.
Weirder things have happened at the SCP Foundation
than having an evil twin, so maybe someone
could make the excuse that their evil twin
committed some crime on their behalf.
But the Bright family is one of the most well-known
dynasties in Foundation history, so nobody
is going to believe that there’s a hidden
member of the family still out there.
Maybe if SCP-963 had a perfect copy, you might
have an excuse here.
But to the best of our knowledge, that is
not the case.
Take your lumps, Jack.